celebration of life was held at sunset  park tonight for the three-year-old who  passed away in a fire last month kaden  meacham died after an accidental fire in  a mobile home and tonight loved ones  dressed up as  superheroes because caden just really  loved them they also lit candles in his  honor as they try to move past what has  been a very difficult few weeks  it's hard to feel happy it's basically  you know we  wanted to celebrate christmas because we  had the other kids  but it was sad because we didn't have  caden  so every year we're going to fill that i  think  one of the photos that you see here at  tonight's ceremony was made entirely of  legos his grandmother tells us it was  actually created by cayden's mom